[موسيقى]
مرحبا كان اسبوعا للكوارث الطبيعيه
بامتياز بدا بزلز الارض في المغرب ولم
ينتهي باعصار غير مسبوق في ليبيا مرورا
بما يشبه النداء الاخير للاستغاثه من
الجفاف المحتمل في مصر والسودان مع اكتمال
ملء سد النهضه الاثيوبي بالمياه واذا كان
الحدثان الاولان لا علاقه للانسان بحدوثه
ما بل بعواقب عدم الاعداد لهما فان سد
النهضه في اثيوبيا والخراب في مصر
والسودان كما يصفه دائما احمد ابو الغيط
هو كارثه غير طبيعيه قد تعادل عره اضعاف
قوه النظام والميليشيات السوريه على مقياس
التهجير والتجويع حيث اصبح المليون ليره
سوريه الذي يعادل على الاقل خمسه اضعاف
راتب الموظف العادي يكفي ثلاثه ايام فقط
لعيش اسره صغيره حياه بسيطه في سوريا الى
العناوين اعصار دانيال يغير على ليبيا
نداء استغاثه راهم الناس
حاصلين سد النهضه امتل ويهدد الامن المائي
لمصر
والسودان اربع دول عربيه ستكون خاليه من
البشر في نهايه
القرن البرهان يسقط الصفه القانونيه عن
قوات الدعم
السريع اسرائيل تربط الهند بالعرب واوروبا
ومرفا حيف يلغي بيروت
محمود عباس متهم بمعاداته
وباريس تنزع عنه
وسامها لماذا قال صدام حسين لمعمر القذافي
والدك في
النار محاكمه يزيد بن معاويه في محاكم
العراق بتهمه قتل
[موسيقى]
الحسين نبدا باعصار دانيال الذي ضرب شرق
ليبيا قادما من اليونان التي اشتهر خفر
سواحلها بالقاء المهاجرين غير النظاميين
القادمين من شواطئ ليبيا في البحر اما هذه
المره فقد اتى الاعصار الى ليبيا من
اليونان دون دعوه سيول جارفه سحبت معها
الاخضر واليابس وغمرت قرى ومدنا للابد هنا
في شرق ليبيا الذي خرجت منه نداءات
الاستغاثه نجده بعد ان فعل الاعصار دانييل
فعلته في اراضي الليبيين الفان قتيل والاف
المفقودين والعدد في ارتفاع مستمر ليبيا
تعلن الحداد وصلت العاصفه دانييل ايضا الى
مصر يوم الاثنين وضربت محافظتين في شمال
البلاد هما مرسى مطروح والاسكندريه بحكومه
واحده وامكانيات هائله احتاجت تركيا الى
مساعدات من جميع انحاء العالم لاغاثه
متضرري زلزالها الاخير فكيف باعصار ليبيا
المتعدده الحكومات والرؤوس والجيوش اما ان
لليبيين ان يثبتوا للعالم بانهم قادرون
على انتاج حكم مدني غير عسكري وانهم لم
يدمن حكم الطاغوت يا ليبيا يا جنه انت عشق
فرض سنه يشتهر الشعب الليبي بحنو على
الضعيف واغاثه الملهوف وهكذا يفعلون في
الافراح فكيف
بالممات ام تبحث عن سياره لزفاف ابنها
وشباب بنغازي يجعلونه الاكبر في تاريخ
المدينه ناشدت الام قبيل عرس ابنها عبر
الانترنت ان يرشدها من يعرف الى استئجار
سياره متواضعه ليوم زفاف ابنها وبعد نشر
الرساله في صفحه اجتماعيه في المدينه لم
يكتفي المتابعون بالارشاد الى سياره عاديه
بل جعلوها فخمه وتقدمه بل حضرت سيارات
بنغازي بالاضافه الى الشاحنات المزينه
وكان عرسا اسطوريا حتى لا يقال ان عروسين
محدودي الدخل لم يفرح يوم زفافهما كبقيه
الناس في ليبيا تلك هي ليبيا في افراح
فكيف تكون في الاتراح بكل تاكيد انها يد
واحده الكارثه في المغرب كانت عنيفه جدا
بل الاعنف منذ 100 عام وقد نقلت الجزيره
ادق تفاصيلها وارقامها لحظه بلحظه سنحاول
هنا الابتعاد عن الحصاد المرير والمشاهد
المؤلمه التي طبعت شاشتنا على مدى اسبوع
فالله تعالى يبتلي ويعين وقد اعان
المنكوبين بفزعه وطنيه مغربيه ساندت
القطاع العام وشملت البشر والشجر وحتى
الحيوانات الاليفه وسجلت مئات المشاهد
الانسانيه ما يخاطر بنفسه مثلا لانقاذ قطه
من تحت انقاض الزلزال سيستبدل
انتشال الناس من مصابين وعالق
وضحايا
اشي اسبح الله العظيم ايشي اشي قريه
مغربيه اختفت وبقي مسجدها ثابتا على
اطلالها دائره امرز جان بلده مغربيه سويت
بالارض خلال ثوان معدودات وتناقلت المواقع
صورها قبل الزلزال وبعده لا نريد ان نعطي
تفسيرات روحيه للحدث بدون علم حتى لو دمر
الزلزال المسجد لكان حدثا عاديا وقد دمرت
الزلازل والفيضانات والاعاصير غيره حول
العالم فهل ان من بنى مسجد امر زجان انفق
على بنائه بشكل هندسي سليم مقاوم للهزات
الارضيه هناك فيديو ل لقريه صغيره قريبه
من جماعه ايغيل ايغيل مركز الزلزال باقليم
الحوز دمرت عن اخي اخها وفقط مسجد المدينه
مسجد القريه نجى من
[موسيقى]
الدمار حول لي ولا
قوه الا
بالاله
العلي العظيم
[موسيقى]
اللهم صل على
المصطفى
حبيب
محمد عليه
السلام
حبيبنا
محمد عليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام
زلزال اليمن الاصطناعي بفعل الحروب
والانقسامات
متواصل والتقارير تتحدث عن وفره الجوع
وندره المياه المياه النظيفه الصالحه
للشرب او حتى للاستخدامات الشخصيه يفتقر
للمياه الامنه 15 مليون يمني اي ما يعادل
عدد سكان دولتي السويد والنرويج مجتمع
اكثر من 15 مليون يمني يفتقرون للمياه
النظيفه الصالحه للاستخدام جراء الندره
المزمنه للمياه والتي تفاقمت بسبب النزاع
طويل الامد مصحوبا بالتغير المناخي الذي
ادى الى جفاف غير مسبوق هل بلغ عداد
الجفاف مراحله الاخيره في مصر والسودان مع
اعلان رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا ابي احمد عن
اكتمال المرحله الرابعه والاخيره من مل
اسد النهضه الذي وصفته الخارجيه المصريه
بانه تهديد للامن المائي والماء اساس كل
شيء حي تطور جديد في ملف سد النهضه المثير
للجدل بعد ما اعلنت السلطات الاثيوبيه
انها اكملت المرحله الرابعه والاخيره من
ملء خزان السد وشددت الخارجيه المصريه على
ان اتخاذ اثيوبيا مثل هذه الاجراءات
الاحاديه يعد تجاهلا لمصالح دولتي المصب و
حقوقهما وامنه المائيه في هذا الوقت وزاره
التربيه في مصر تقرر حضر النقاب في
المدارس لكن الكمامه مسموحه والنظارات
مسموحه فاذا كان القصد من حظر النقاب منع
اخفاء الوجه فهم يسمحون باخفائه بالكمامات
والنظارات اما اذا كان القصد منع المظاهر
الاسلاميه فسلم لي عليه وبوس لي عينيه وق
ق له اني بسلم عليه لماكرون بالاذن من
السيده فيروز قرار وزاري بحظر النقاب بين
طالبات المدارس المصريه بعد امتلاء سد
النهضه احد مذيعي السهرات المفتوحه في مصر
فاض الكيل فيه فطالب الحكومه بالوقوف على
مسؤولياتها وسد حاجه الشعب الى المراحيض
العامه غير المجانيه ليصبح شرب الماء
والتخلص منه بفلوس بيت
الراحه دورات مياه حمام حقوق الانسان يا
بتوع حقوق الانسان مش بتبتدي من السياسه
مش بتبتدي من مش عارف ايه والحقوق
السياسيه دي بتبتدي ان انا اعيش طب انا
ينفع اعيش محصور ينفع اعيش مزنوق ولازم
يبقى بيت الراحه ده او الحمام ده العمومي
ده موجود في الشوارع والميادين
بكثره احنا لو اتعملت عندنا ب 5 جنيه ب 10
جنيه بس وانت محصور وهتموت وبتاع فخش
تلاقي مكان نظيف تعمل فيه حاجتك وتغسل
ايدك وبتاع وك وتدفع خ ماعتقدش فيها مشكله
لمن يريد ليست المغرب وليبيا واليمن ومصر
والسودان بل ان اجزاء كبيره اخرى من الشرق
الاوسط ستصبح غير صالحه للعيش الادمي بفعل
الجفاف والتغيرات
المناخيه بحلول نهايه القرن لبنان من ضمن
هذه المناطق يقول التقرير
علما ان اللبنانيين بدا زعمائهم بتجفيف
جيوب مواطنيهم من الاموال وكل سنه بقولوا
هيدي اخر سنه قنا على
الكوكب من اجل مواجهه الهجره غير الشرعيه
يقترح الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
تنظيم هجره قانونيه من مصر الى الدول
الاوروبيه التي تعاني نقص المواليد
والايدي العامله اذا نجحت الخطه سيتمنى
سكان دول عربيه اخرى لو كانوا مصريين حتى
يهاجروا يبقى النهارده لو في نقص في
العماله في اي دوله ممكن قوي قوي يتم
التنسيق والتفاهم ويبقى تقديم العماله
بشكل او باخر لمده زمنيه محدده ثم تعود
هذه العماره مره اخرى الى دولنا والدول
المشابهه لينا الليره بخير قالها قبل ثلاث
سنوات حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه المتهم
دوليا الان بالفساد فتبين ان وضعه ووضع
المنظومه الحاكمه بخير في المصارف
السويسريه وغيرها ليس الا انا مرتاح انتم
قالين الدولار متوفر بلبنان الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد يطلب من محافظ البنك
المركزي مروان العباسي طمانه المواطنين
الى ان عملتهم الوطنيه بسلامه لكن ليس على
طريقه رياض سلامه حاكم مصرف لبنان فتونس
بعيده عن الافلاس يقول سعيد لكن وزيره
الماليه التونسيه سهام نمص حذرت مطلع الس
الحاليه من افلاس الدوله التونسيه نفى
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان تكون بلاده
على حفه الافلاس ودع محافظ بنك بلاده
المركزي مروان العباسي الى طمانه
التونسيين هل صحيح ما يتناقل عن موظف سابق
في وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
قوله كنا لابعاد الشبهات عن عملائنا ندرج
في قوائم العقوبات
لا ندري لكن بعيدا عن الفكره عقوبات
امريكيه تفرض على نائب قائد قوات الدعم
السريع السودانيه حمتي شقيقه عبد الرحيم
دجلو والتهمه ارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق
الانسان الولايات المتحده تتهم دجلو
بالضلوع في اعمال عنف وانتهاكات لحقوق
الانسان والمشاركه في مذبحه ضد المدنيين
وقتل عرقي واستخدام العنف الجنسي رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
يسقط الصفه شبه الرسميه عن قوات الدعم
السريع ويحولها بمرسوم دستوريين الى
ميليشيا خارجه على القانون علما ان
القانون في السودان اله عزف باوتار طيعه
لانابيل من يستحوذ عليها جدل عميق يسود
بين الاوساط السودانيه بعد قرار رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان حل قوات الدعم
السريع والغاء
[موسيقى]
قانونها رئيس وزراء الاحتلال بنيامين
نتنياهو يعلن مزهوا عن مشروع ربط الهند
باوروبا والشرق الاوسط عبر اسرائيل ولماذا
لا يكون الاسرائيليون مزهو وهم عملوا بجد
لاجل باطل سكت عنه اهل الحقوق وطبل للباطل
مع
المطبلين لا حسبما هو ظاهر في الخارطه
التي يقف امامها نتنياهو محاولا تقليد
الزميل صهيب العصا كما تندر الزملاء فان
الممر سيعبر مرفا حيفا شمالا وليس لبنان
الذي الغى حضوره الانفجار التاريخي لرفا
بيروت قبل نحو ثلاث سنوات ف مصائب العرب
كلها فوائد لاسرائيل الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس متهم بمعاداته لانه قال ان
هتلر قتل اليهود بسبب احترافهم الربا وليس
بسبب
ديانتهم كما نفى ان يكون اليهود الاشكناز
يهود الستات الاوروبي من العرق السامي
الدنيا امطرت على عباس ادانات ام يه
واوربيه اعتبرت ان كلامه اساءه للشعب
اليهودي فهل تهتم الحكومات الناعمه
والحساسه ايضا لمشاعر المسلمين وتمنع حرق
المصاحف الشريفه في ساحاتها بترخيص من
قضاتها وحمايه من شرطتها رئيسه بلديه
باريس قررت تجريد الرئيس الفلسطيني من
ارفع اوسمه العاصمه الفرنسيه بعد تصريحاته
حول المحرقه عندما قالوا ان هتلر قتل
اليهود لانهم يهود وان اوروبا تكره اليهود
لانهم يهود لا شرحت بالضبط على انه حاربوا
هؤلاء بسبب وظيفتهم
الاجتماعيه وليس بسبب دياناتهم تتعلق
بالربا والاموال وغيرها وغيرها وغيرها
ليسوا
ساميين ولا علاقه لهم بساميه عناق حار جدا
بين الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون ورئيس
وزراء الهند ناريندرا مودي في نيو ديلهي
على هامش قمه العشرين نشر الصوره ماكرون
معلقا العالم عائله واحده فهل سيمنع
ماكرون النقطه الحمراء على جبين الهنديات
في مدارسه كما قرر منع الطالبات المسلمات
من ارتداء الملابس الفضفاضه الطوي
وهل بهذا يصبح العالم عائله واحده مودي
الذي بدا في قاعه القمه في قمه الفخر
باعتماده الاسم الاصولي لبلاد الهند
بهرات لم يكن فخورا ابدا بفقراء بلاده
فبمناسبة
[موسيقى]
عشوائيه لتجميل المنظر وامرت الفقراء بعدم
الظهور في الشوارع العامه ريثما تنتهي قمه
العشرين كما شملت التشطيبات النهائيه
لتزييف الواقع وضع سور عازل من الستائر
الخضراء تعلوها صور كبير البهارات رئيس
الوزراء ناريندرا
مودير جا
[موسيقى]
ما هي تفاصيل المشاده العابره للاجواء بين
الزعيمين الراحلين صدام حسين ومعمر
القذافي ولماذا قال صدام لمعمر والدك في
النار سفير العلاقه الاسبق في ليبيا علي
سبت الحديث يجيب شبكه روسيا اليوم دلعت
الحرب بين العراق وايران بشكلها الواسع
يوم 22 امعمر بعث برقيه الى الرئيس صدام
يقول له هذه الحرب عبثيه والقتلى كلهم في
النار لانهم كلهم مسلمين الرئيس دام يقول
له للرئيس معمر يقول
له قتلانا في
الجنه وقتلاهم وابوك في النار وابوك نعم
ابو القذافي يعني نعم بتهمه قتل الامام
الحسين رضي الله عنه قبل مئات السنين
دعاوه قضائيه في محاكم العراق ضد يزيد بن
معاويه فهل ما زالت بغداد تقرا ما تكتبه
القاهره وتطبعه بيروت كما يقول المثل
العربي الحديث
يسعى حقوقيون
عراقيون لرفع عدد من الدعاوى
القضائيه في عدد من
محاكم العراق والموضوع ضد المته هم يزيد
بن معاويه وذلك عن اقدامه على ارتكاب عدد
من الجرائم الكبرى
بتعمد قتل الامام الحسين عليه السلام زين
اذا كسبوا الدعوه منين يجيبوا يزيد الباحث
السياسي العراقي عبد القادر النايل يجيب
متوجسا من احداث عنف طائفي جديده لكن
رافعي الدعاوى على يزيد لم يقولوا ابدا ان
هدفهم منها اي ترجمه لها على ارض الواقع
هذه الدعوات رغم انها مثيره للسخريه لكنها
حقيقه لها
تبعات على ارض الواقع لان من يدعي اقامه
هكذا دعاوه هم من يحملون السلاح وهم من
يقتلون الناس على اسس طائفيه فلذلك لها
خطورتها يبدو ان بعض الزوار الايرانيين
الى اربعينيه استشهاد الامام الحسين رضي
الله عنه قطع عرضوا لبعض الاساءات وسط
الزحام الشديد فقدم مواطن عراقي اعتذارا
على طريقته الخاصه ونيابه عن الشعب
العراقي كما قال انا اعتذر بطريقتي
الخاصه اقدم اعتذاري نيابه عن كل عراقي
شريف نيابه عن كل عراقي شريف وانا اقدم
اعتذاري الطريقه الخاصه للاخوان من
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه كل واحد اساء للزوار
الايرانيين انا اعتذر بطريقتي
الخاصه انا اعتذر بطريقتي الخاصه نيابه
نيابه عن كل عراق شريف يعتقد بعض الشيعه
ان نبي الله يونس عليه السلام عندما
ابتلعه الحوت استغاث بالامام علي رضي الله
عنه وقال يا علي فقذف الحوت من جوفه هذا
العام شهدت طقوس الاربعينيه الحسين
استحضار مجسم تعبيري لما وصف بحوت يونس
ووضعت جثه رمزيه مكفنه في فمه يونس من
غرا نادى يا
[موسيقى]
علي يا
علي يا حاضر الشداد اخيرا لا تتفاجا اذا
قرات في الايام القادمه خبرا يفيد بان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يتوجه في هذه
اللحظات الى الحمام لاخذ دوش شاور فهو
بايدن اعلن خلال مؤتمر صحفي في هانوي
بفيتنام انه ذاهب الى الفراش للنوم عندما
كان يتحدث عن الرئيس الصيني سيجين
بين
[موسيقى]
ختاما لحديث اكثر طلاقه ينشر المتخصصون ست
نصائح قد تساعد في التغلب على التلعثم
والثا اولا استرخي وتنفس بعمق قبل التفاعل
الاجتماعي ثانيا لا تتعجل في كلامك بل
تحدث ببطء
ورويه فان حرصك على التحدث بسرعه لاظهار
الطلاقه والسلاسه في الحديث قد يؤدي الى
نتائج عكسيه ثالثا جهز لمحادثتك بشكل جيد
لان الارتجال وعدم التحضير مدخل ممتاز
للتلعثم
رابعا تدرب على المحادثه بمساعده مدرب
متخصص او مع صديق بعيدا عن ضغط المراقبه
خامسا دع جسدك تحرك ويتفاعل تلقائيا مع
حديثك ليتوزع التوتر فيتلا شى سادسا
واخيرا لا تتحدث بنمط لحنيه بل اترك لفهمك
للكلام ان يتحكم بايقاع ومواقع السكوت
والضغط ورفع الصوت وخفضه احرص جيدا على
هذه النصائح كي لا تحول الضرر الى ضرير
الى اللقاء زين لا ضرير ولا ر لا ضر ولا
ضرار لا ضرار ولا ضرير لا ضرار و زين خ
خله
[موسيقى]
يروح